all right welcome back everybody so I'm
going to start off with a couple of
announcements and then we're gonna dive
into some more linear systems of Odie's
okay so I have today's lecture and
Friday's lecture online now so I'm
finally more than one day ahead of
schedule so I know what I'll be doing on
Friday and I actually know what I'll be
doing next week - now just good on
Monday I'm gonna be in California and so
I will not be here but I'm gonna try to
get one of my TAS to come so there will
be kind of a question and answer period
you don't have to come to that but if
you have any questions about what we've
been doing up until lecture five it
might be a good chance to ask for a
little more clarification okay
homework instructions I've been it's
been made it's been brought to my
attention that I haven't actually told
you how to turn in homeworks so there's
a few ways to do this you could turn in
homeworks in person just like a staple
bunch of paper in the Friday class okay
or if you want you can email the
homeworks to both of the TAS and myself
okay if you do that please have a
reasonable subject like me5 sixty for
homework one submission or me5 sixty for
homework one submission edge if you're
on the edge online so there's some of
the problems involve MATLAB you know
plots and codes definitely include your
plots you know if you think that there
might be some chance of partial credit
you might want to include your code also
but I don't think you strictly speaking
have to include your code only if you do
something wrong okay I expect all
figures to be you know adequately
labeled X label Y label legend like it
should be a publication quality figure
okay and I'm not looking for a stack of
like fifty pages you know be reasonable
okay
okay good homework I'm out of town on
Monday but I'll be back on Wednesday and
Friday another announcement so many of
you have probably heard that the
mechanical engineering department has a
current and ongoing research engagement
with Boeing and so I will be taking
either one or two students this year to
work on Boeing related projects this is
kind of a big data meets mechanical
engineering project so we're gonna be
dealing with large amounts of point
cloud data from the wing assembly of an
aircraft if any of you and there's also
three other projects so controls
projects and more manufacturing and so
if any of you are looking for research
funding or interesting research projects
and would either like to work with me or
with any of the other professors
involved in this boeing initiative
please send me an email saying you know
i'm interested and attached to your cv
and we're going to start reviewing them
in the next week or two okay it's all of
my announcements all right let's start
doing some math
good okay
so what we're gonna talk about today
we're gonna go a little bit deeper into
the harmonic oscillator so this is a
second order linear differential
equation okay so we're gonna go into the
harmonic oscillator and we're gonna look
at four different ways to solve this
okay so we've already seen a couple of
ways of solving differential equations
we're gonna think about a couple of more
ways you know including Taylor series
we're gonna guess some solutions and
others then we're gonna look at the
damped harmonic oscillator and the idea
is that with the damped harmonic
oscillator we're going to build up to
higher order differential equations
higher order linear ode ease
so instead of just having like X double
dot plus x equals 0
I might have you know X quadruple dot
plus 5x triple dot plus 2x dot equals 0
right I can have a bunch of derivatives
and all of their relationships okay so
we're gonna be building up to higher
order linear ode e's and on friday we're
going to figure out how to write this in
a very general form using matrix systems
of Oddi ease and next week we're gonna
jump into linear algebra eigenvalues
eigenvectors and how to really solve big
systems of ordinary differential
equations okay so that's where we're
going but I want to spend just a little
bit more time so this is most of today
kind of building the framework for when
we get into higher order systems any
questions about what we've done in the
first three lectures or where we're
going okay
okay good
so last time we had this spring-mass
system a mass M spring k and we had our
Newton's law which said M X double dot
equals minus KX okay and for now we're
just going to set mass equals to 1
spring equals to 1 because we don't want
to deal with any constants okay so we're
just going to start with X double dot
equals minus X okay we're going to look
at a few different ways of solving this
today remember X is just the
displacement of this mass from
equilibrium okay and at the end of last
lecture we talked a little bit about
this physically this is a really simple
system we can kind of picture in our
minds what's going to happen so if I
pull this mass off of equilibrium and
let go it's just going to oscillate back
and forth it's going to swing from
positive through zero to negative then
it's gonna swing back through zero to
positive and it's just going to keep
oscillating and if there's no friction
it's going to oscillate forever okay so
the first method to solve a differential
equation is just to guess that you know
the solution and try it out that usually
that sometimes works and some of the
best and hardest differential equations
were solved by guessing ok quantum
mechanics special relativity these were
essentially really really educated
guesses by very well-informed physicists
okay so we're gonna guess and we know
that this thing is going to oscillate so
when you think of oscillations what do
you think of sines and cosines ok and
the first time I made these notes I
messed up I put in I guess that the
solution was a sign but that doesn't
really make sense so if I start this
thing with an initial condition that's a
positive number and I let it go that's
really more like a cosign alright I
start with something like 1 and then I'm
going to eventually go to negative
and then back up to one so this is more
of a cosign type behavior so I'm going
to guess that X of T equals cosine of T
times whatever my initial condition was
X at time 0 that's how much I pull this
thing to displace it before letting go
okay and if I if I pull this mass to
some initial position X 0 and then I
just let it go are there any other
initial conditions we have any other
information I have about the system the
first derivative must be zero so X dot
of 0 has to be 0 okay this is an
important condition ok so I'm going to
take this guess I'm going to take its
derivatives and we're going to plug it
in and make sure that we guessed
correctly ok so X dot time is minus sine
T X naught is just a number so it just
stays out here X double dot T is minus
cos T X naught and so if I plug in X
double dot I really do have minus X and
so this is a solution ok and just as a
sanity check sine of 0 is 0 so X dot of
0 is 0 this thing starts with 0 initial
velocity like we planned it ok good ok
and for general M and K so for any mass
M at any spring constant K we have X of
T is equal to coasts so what's the
natural frequency of the system
sorry okay so the natural frequency is
going to be the square root of K divided
by M so we have cosine of square root K
divided by M times time times X naught
okay so this is kind of the general
solution you could have solved this
equally well by assuming that X of T
equals Coast's lambda T and then solving
for what lambda has to equal for this
equation to balance okay and lambda
would have to equal square root of K
over m okay that's one method to solve
this pretty simple this isn't going to
be the best way of solving differential
equations okay we want principled ways
of solving systems that we don't kind of
know the answer already okay let's see
okay so let's do another another method
of solution
okay so method two let's try a Taylor
series now this is kind of nice because
great we're just starting out the fourth
lecture of the class and already you
have the basic foundational tools to
solve I would say 90% of the ODS we're
gonna solve in this class which is using
Taylor series okay we're gonna derive
cleaner simpler forms of the solution
from the Taylor series but you can
always start to solve a differential
equation by just assuming that you have
a differentiable function it has a
Taylor series and backing out what that
function has to be to satisfy that
differential equation okay so this is
one of the techniques that should carry
with you for the rest of your lives okay
this is this is the most one of the most
general ways of solving a differential
equation okay just assume a Taylor
series that's why I'm kind of hammering
at home it's a little dry it's a little
boring but when you find yourself you
know in the qualifying exam or on a
desert island you can always plug in a
Taylor series and solve for your
differential equation okay
desert island and qualifying exams are
actually remarkably similar okay so we
assume that our function can be written
as an expansion in time so there's some
coefficient constant term plus C 1 T
plus C 2 T squared plus C 3 T cubed plus
dot dot dot dot maybe I'll write one
more term plus C 4 T to the fourth plus
dot dot dot dot dot if I wanted to write
this as plus order what would be what
would the order be t to the fifth right
I've neglected everything T to the fifth
and higher so it just gets lumped into
this order T to the fifth term okay and
I can take the first and second
derivatives and then plug it into my
formula okay so I'll just do that really
quickly the first derivative is C 1 plus
2 C 2 T plus 3 C 3 T squared
+4 c 4 t cubed plus dot that dot dot and
X double dot is okay constant one goes
away and I have two times C 2 plus three
times two C three times time okay just
the chain rule right this 2t t squared
the derivative is 2t plus 4 times 3 C 4
T squared and I'll just write out the
last term
5 times 4 C 5 T to the cube plus dot dot
dot okay the second derivative and now
we're just going to set X double dot
equals minus X we're gonna solve for
these coefficients and back out what the
solution has to be okay so what's the
general procedure what do I do
I don't want this to be like a formula
right this is supposed to mean something
so I assumed I have a function that I
can take a Taylor series expansion of
I've taken its derivatives I'm going to
plug it into the differential equation
now what I do I compare the coefficients
which coefficients how do I know which
coefficients to compare
by the powers of T right so I'm going to
start with my constant terms here and I
get you know C 2 equals 1/2 C 0 ok good
then I'm going to look at my first T to
the 0 term
so C 1 equals 3 times 2 times C 3 sorry
Sarah - - there's a definitely a minus
here and C 3 equals 1/3 times 2 C 1
ok we've taken the T to the 1 power and
made it equal the minus comes from the
fact that we're making these
coefficients equal and opposite okay
good
and now let's just do a couple more so C
4 is going to be okay so C 4 is minus 1
over 4 times 3 times C 2 right and C 2
was minus 1 over 2 C 0 so this is the
minuses cancel and I get 1 over 4
factorial 4 times 3 times 2 times C 0
that makes sense
there's any questions if I'm going too
fast like please stop me this is
important ok now this is almost useful
it's not quite useful yet how do I
really make this expression actually
useful
I need to plug in my initial conditions
right so I have this recursive
relationship I know what c2 is in terms
of C 0 C 3 in terms of c1 c4 in terms of
C 2 and hence C 0 I'll know C 5 in terms
of C 3 and hence C 1 and so on and so
forth to infinity but I actually want
numbers I don't want you know a constant
in terms of a constant I want numbers so
I'm going to plug in my initial
condition and we have here two initial
conditions so let's plug in time zero
into this expression we get C 0 equals
our initial position ok X naught is our
initial position of this mass that has
to be C 0 if I plug in x 0 into my
expression for X I get C 0 and if I plug
in x 0 into the derivative position I
get C 1 so C 1 equals x dot at 0 this is
my initial velocity ok and finally we
get ok now C 2 is equal to minus 1/2 X
naught C 3 is equal to 1 over 3
factorial X dot naught C 4 is 1 over 4
factorial X naught and so on and so
forth okay so all of the even terms C 0
C 2 C 4 are going to multiply initial
positions and all of the odd terms C 1 C
3 C 5 are going to multiply X dot 0 the
initial velocities so this separates my
solution into cosine times my initial
position plus sine times my initial
velocity so if I had an initial velocity
it would have a sign component okay so
I'm just going to write out the solution
over here
see three should have a minus sign yeah
sorry I keep forgetting my - and this is
really important this would not be
signed if I didn't have a minus sign
thank you for for fixing that so it
should go plus plus minus minus plus
plus minus minus plus plus minus minus
forever okay thank you so in our problem
we assumed that there was no initial
velocity so we're going to assume X dot
naught equals zero and then all of our
terms are X of T equals okay we're gonna
have 1 minus 1 over 2 factorial T
squared plus 1 over 4 factorial T to the
fourth minus 1 over 6 factorial T to the
6 times X 0 okay that's just taking all
of the terms that have an X 0
coefficients and this function of course
is cosine right this is cosine of T
let's say I don't want to make this
assumption it seems silly I just spent
all this time deriving a really kind of
general Taylor series expansion let's
say that I do have an X dot of 0 then I
just take all of my odd terms and I also
have write C 1 is C 1 times T so I have
t minus T cubed over 3 factorial plus T
to the fifth over 5 factorial minus T to
the seventh over 7 factorial times X dot
at 0 times my initial velocity and this
is sine of T so now we actually have the
very very general solution to this
problem
if I have some initial position so I
have my mass I pull it to some initial
position X naught let's say I push it a
little so it has an initial velocity X
dot not then my general solution is
Coastie X naught plus sine T times the
initial velocity okay this is a lot more
general than what we guessed we just
guessed a cosine this is more general I
wouldn't have guessed this exact form of
the solution so the Taylor series really
helped us out okay does this make sense
how we did this yeah so why do we assume
that x equals powers of sum of powers of
T because most of us are familiar with
Taylor series expansion and lots of
functions we care about can be written
nicely in Taylor series expansion but
you're hitting on a really key point so
the solution that we get for this
harmonic oscillator is actually poorly
represented in Taylor series
I need all infinite powers of T to
capture sines and cosines and there's a
better basis so this is a basis constant
power single power of T second power of
T third power of T this is a basis for
general functions
okay so we're used to thinking of vector
spaces well this is a basis for a
function space and you can write sine in
this Taylor series function space but
it's kind of a bad basis for sines and
cosines so in the future and probably in
five sixty five we're going to introduce
the Fourier transform and we're going to
be writing our solutions in terms of
sines and cosines and sines of two Omega
T's and three Omega T's and four Omega
T's which are really really good basis
for certain times of physical types of
physical systems this is a really good
basis for other types of physical
systems okay but right now we're just
using this because it's very general
it's deeply tied to calculus and it's
something we can use for computations
okay yeah it's a really really good
question
okay other questions about the Taylor
series so if I gave you another
differential equation do you think you
could solve it using a Taylor series
maybe okay
well what are the key steps so what's
the first step
sorry okay you could make a guess that
it could be written as a Taylor series
expansion okay and then like if I have X
double dot plus two X dot plus x equals
zero let's say I want to solve this
using the Taylor series expansion this
might be a homework problem we're close
to a homework problem so I make a guess
that X can be written as expansion and
powers of t then what's the second step
well I take all of the derivatives up
until the highest order of this
differential equation okay so I need to
take a first derivative and a second
derivative if I had a plus X triple dot
I need to take a third derivative too
okay so the second step is to take all
of the derivatives that I need to
capture all the terms in my equation
okay I could even have nasty terms like
x times X dot no problem okay we're not
going to do that right now but I could
what's the third step so the
coefficients equal right so now I know
what the maybe I'll wait on this case
okay so now I take the t to the zero
power from each of these derivatives and
I set all of their coefficients equal to
zero I take the T to the one
coefficients and I set all of their
coefficients equal to zero the T squared
and I set all their coefficients and so
on and so forth to infinity right dot
dot dot and then I can get a recursive
relationship of higher coefficients in
terms of earlier coefficients and then I
plug in my initial conditions and I have
an entire expression in terms of X
naught X naught dots X naught double
dots if I have a third order equation X
naught triple dots if I have a fourth
order equation and so on and so forth
okay very very general procedure this is
kind of the third step is plugging in
the coefficients and the fourth step is
plugging in the initial conditions to
actually get values for those those
coefficients okay
so I think you should be able to do this
now for most differential equations you
know I'm not going to give you anything
nasty like that's triple primes or
quadruple dots or anything like that you
should probably be able to solve this so
you can practice this is on the homework
something you could do is a system like
this this is a pretty common one we'll
come back to this one later so you could
take the Taylor series expansion for X
dots and multiply it by the Taylor
series expansion of X and you could get
your constant terms and your first order
terms and your second order terms and
you could actually do the exact same
thing for products of X's and X dots and
X double dots and it's a huge pain in
the ass but this is how Bessel functions
are derived okay so you actually do this
for nonlinear functions right this is
what people did before Mathematica when
they had a bottle of whiskey and paper
okay good other questions about Taylor
series expansions so this is on the
homework if you have questions this is
the time all the homework like this all
by hand this is no I mean like compute
the Taylor series expansion solve for
the coefficients using recursion plug in
your initial conditions write down the
solution exactly yeah
yeah I know one of them our problems
have asks us to plot and everything's in
terms of variables do you want to pick
some initial values and plot those or
just general yeah pick some initial
values and plot those yeah exactly
okay good I'll do a MATLAB example at
the end of class okay so I'm gonna do
one two other ways of solving this
system okay so the third method is also
going to be pretty important at least
for linear systems of equations so this
Taylor series is really what you do when
you don't know what else to do okay if
you don't know what your solution is and
it's not in terms of some simple
functions and it's nasty and nonlinear
you can always go back to Taylor series
okay so method 3 is another guess okay
so what function when I take its
derivative is equal to itself up to a
constant e to the lambda X right so X of
T equals e to the lambda T when I take
the derivative its lambda e to the
lambda T that's equal to lambda X okay
so it's equal to itself times a constant
so all linear differential equations
every single one of them this one if I
added plus 19 X fifth fourth derivative
all linear higher order differential
equations are gonna have solutions like
this we can prove it but I don't think
any of us want to prove things right
we're gonna see why this is true and so
we're gonna guess that this is the
solution and then we're going to derive
what lambda has to be okay
so we're going to say X dot of T equals
lambda e to the lambda T and X double
dot T equals lambda squared
e to the lambda T and so if I have X
double dot equals minus X then I have
lambda squared e to the lambda T equals
minus e to the lambda T and this can
only be true when lambda squared equals
minus one okay so what is lambda have to
be what numbers 1 squared give me minus
1 and minus I I am - I work yeah - I
works so lambda equals plus n - I write
two solutions second-order equation at
lambda plus and minus I ok and last time
we computed the Taylor series of things
like e to the I T and e to the minus I T
so we know that we can write these in
terms of cosines and sines ok so what
this means if we have two solutions
lambda that make this work then we're
going to have two terms in our
differential equation solution X of T
equals some coefficient 1 maybe we'll
make these caves k1 e to the lambda 1 so
e to the I T plus k2 e to the minus I T
okay that's going to be the generic
solution so I assume that my system has
this form I claim that all linear
equations linear Odie's are gonna have
this form I plug it into my differential
equation and I get some equation some
polynomial in lambda that has to be
satisfied and every root of lambda that
satisfies this equation is going to be a
term in my differential equation ok so
this is you know k 1 e to the lambda 1 T
plus K 2 e to the lambda 2 T
okay how do I get k1 and k2 initial
conditions yeah okay so x0 okay I'm
going to plug in T equals 0 in this
equation what do I get
k1 plus k2 e to the 0 e to the 0 always
equals 1 so this is k1 plus k2 now if I
take the derivative of this I get okay I
get i k e to the i t i k1 minus I K to
each of the I T so when T equals zero
what is that equal right I times k1
minus k2 so these are kind of two
equations with two unknowns K 1 and K 2
we don't know K 1 we don't know K 2
but we do know X naught and the initial
velocity X dot naught at time 0 just to
simplify the math I'm going to assume
that this is equal to 0 but you can kind
of do this for the general case when you
actually have an X dot naught and let's
see so okay so if this X dot if my
initial velocity is 0 what is it what
has to be true with k1 and k2 they have
to be equal okay so k1 equals k2 and
then if I plug k1 equals k2 into here I
get 2 times k1 equals X naught so k1
equals k2 equals x naught over 2 okay
those are my initial conditions
so I'm going to plug them into here
and I'm going to get X of T equals X
naught over two times
what's eat of the eye T cosine T plus I
sine T and what's eetu the - I T
literally just plug in minus T here this
is an even function so it's still just
coasts T this is minus I sine T so
coasts t minus I sine T my sine I T and
my minus I sine T's cancel and I have X
not coasts T okay so it's another way of
solving this system this is how we're
gonna solve all linear systems okay so
this is this is kind of the most useful
way of solving linear systems they're
always going to be some combination of e
to the lambda T's so we plug in X of T
equals e to the lambda T we compute all
the derivatives we need to so we get
this polynomial in that lambda and for
every single root of that polynomial for
every value of lambda that makes that
true I get another term e to the lambda
1t e to the lambda 2 T and I use my
initial conditions to solve for what the
coefficients outside have to be okay
this is how we solve all linear
differential equations every single one
of them can be solved this way should we
do one more example yeah okay I'm gonna
do one more example and then we're gonna
plot this in MATLAB and then we're gonna
break okay so the third example is kind
of cool so what do we know about spring
mass systems
what additional forces do we have
usually some kind of dampening or
friction okay so there's some damping D
or Delta so there's also higher-order
terms right if I pull a spring too hard
then I start getting nonlinear forces
it's not just K times X we're gonna deal
with that later for now we're thinking
about linear systems linear models okay
so now we have an equation MX double dot
plus D X dot plus KX equals 0 this is
just F equals MA with a force
proportional damping force proportional
to X dot okay and I'm gonna divide
everything by M so I get X double dot
plus some number I'm gonna call Zeta I
like Zeta it's a cool fun2draw plus
Omega squared X right cuz K over m
square root equals Omega so K divided by
M is omega squared just a nice way of
writing this sum using physics notation
here so this is the system we're gonna
solve what how do we solve this equation
what do we do a little louder
yes what what's easier it's a linear
system right these are all you know
linear coefficients times my term so
what do I do
same thing e to the lambda XI okay so X
of T equals e to the lambda T X dot
equals lambda e to the lambda T X double
dots equals lambda squared e to the
lambda T and I'm gonna plug it in here
okay
so what do I get I get lambda squared e
to the lambda T plus Zeta lambda e to
the lambda T plus Omega squared e to the
lambda T so these all had an e to the
lambda T that I pulled out into the
front x double-dot has a coefficient of
lambda squared X dot has a coefficient
of zeta times lambda and Omega squared X
has a coefficient of Omega squared e to
the lambda T now this function is always
positive so it can't equal zero so the
only way this can ever equal zero is if
this equals zero and when does that
equal zero for what values of lambda
does this quadratic equation equal zero
who remembers the quadratic formula who
doesn't remember the quadratic formula
it's okay this is an important one
okay so just someone tell me what lambda
equals minus Zeta plus or minus the
square root of Zeta squared minus 4
Omega square divided by 2 good ok now if
I have no damping what does that mean
physically like what in this equation
what is no damping mean Zeta equals 0
okay so if I get rid of Zeta what's the
square root of minus 4 Omega squared
plus or minus 2 Omega I divided by 2 is
plus or minus I Omega that's what we
expect that's what we got for the no
damping case so this is at least
consistent with no damping but now this
is the most general form so we can say X
of T equals let's call this lambda 1
comma 2 so the plus case is going to be
lambda 1 the minus case is lambda 2 so X
of T is going to be some constant e to
the lambda 1 T plus some other constant
e to the lambda 2 T and that's actually
the general solution for the spring mass
damper system okay so how would I solve
for constant 1 in constant two initial
conditions I needed something about X
naught and its initial velocity and then
I could kind of solve for what these
have to be and it's actually gonna be
really easy it's going to be exactly the
same as those because at T 0 I don't
care what lambda 1 and lambda 2 are okay
let's do this in MATLAB let's plot some
solutions okay so it's great to do
things by hand but we all have computers
now so let's use them I'm gonna pull
this board down but you have all of
these notes online there you go alright
so the people online can actually hear
me cuss much more clearly than you can I
apologize for that
good okay so we're gonna solve the
spring mass damper system just do some
numerical plotting of this see what it
looks like okay how many of you have
used OD e45 before how many of you have
never touched OD 45 in your entire lives
it's fine okay OD 45 is going to be your
best friend and ordinary differential
equations MATLAB was considerate enough
to give you a function that integrates
numerically basically any differential
equation you can name okay so that's
what we're gonna do clear all close all
CLC okay and what we're gonna do is
we're going to have a natural frequency
of 2 pi we're gonna have a damping ratio
of 0.25 and then I'm going to define my
system so this is probably pretty
important what I can do is write my
system so I had X double dot plus D X
dot plus Omega squared x equals 0 and so
I'm going to write this as a matrix
system of first order equations this is
all we're gonna do on Friday so I'm
going to say X dot equals V some new
dummy variable velocity and V dot is X
double dots
this equals minus Omega squared X minus
D times V X dot is just V okay and so
this is like DDT of X and V equals a
matrix times X and V this is how we're
gonna solve this in MATLAB
okay MATLAB doesn't like higher order
systems of equations it likes first
order linear equations or non-linear
but first order so i'm going to say that
this a matrix equals 0 1 minus W squared
minus 2 times D times Omega because I
apparently don't like Zetas in MATLAB
this is really the D from earlier ok I'm
gonna use a time step of 0.01 and a time
of I'm gonna integrate from time 0 to
time 10 and let's pick an initial
condition what should my initial
condition be okay I take this mass I
pull it to some initial displacement of
what 2 meters good 0 meters per second
right because X naught is 2 V naught is
0 so that's X naught is to 0 this vector
ok and now we're going to solve this in
OD 45 ok so you can always type doc OD e
45 and you'll find that this thing
returns time and the solution variable X
as a vector evaluated at all of those
times I have to give it a function for
the right-hand side I have to give it
this function I have to tell it what
time span I want to integrate from 0 to
10 and what my initial condition is so
pretty simple I gave it three things
this code is going to be online so you
can play around with it a little bit
okay so T comma X is equal to OD 45 now
I have to give it a function of X to
integrate that function of X is this
matrix a times X so that's a function of
X and it's equal to it's a function of
time and X and it's equal to a times X
I'm going to integrate from 0 in
increments of DT up to T equals 10 where
I have to find DT and T and I'm gonna
give it an initial condition of X not
hope this works
test Oh de 45 and it runs okay good so
my code runs it integrated this this
initial content condition I pulled my
mass out to two I let it go it should
oscillate and damp out to zero so I can
plot T by the first column of X so look
at the size of X its you know two big
column vectors with a thousand and one
entries one for X the position and
another column for V the velocity in
time time going down okay so I can plot
T by my first column of X and this is my
position versus time for the spring mass
damper system started it to it swings
past 0 to negative point you know eight
then it swings up to 0.4 but it's
damping out so eventually it goes to
rest at zero okay this is a little bit
quick we're gonna go through this a lot
more you know next time we'll go through
this again I can take my higher order
system of equations and I can write it
as a system of first-order linear
equations and I can solve that in MATLAB
using OD e45
okay I think I have three minutes if
there's any questions about OD 45 yeah
in the back the major ctrl board is
different
today let's call this Zeta and let's
just call this minus Zeta now that's the
same yeah yeah I think I Zita that
should be right Thanks
the D and the Zeta they're off by a
factor of the mass right I'm just
divided by mass I probably messed up
somewhere in my algebra but this still
should work okay other questions about
MATLAB so this at T comma X is called a
function handle this allows me to define
a function on the fly okay so this is a
function of T comma X and if you plug in
X it returns a times X so I could do
this in the command line I could say F
equals at T comma X a times X and if I
said f at time 5 with vector to zero
it's going to give me a times that
vector to zero okay so this is just a
nice way of defining functions on the
fly in MATLAB okay we're going to do
more of this on Friday we're gonna deal
with higher order systems of equations
and put them into matrix form and then
we're gonna start talking about linear
algebra okay thanks
you